today's guest is a uh is an outdoorsman
and indoors many hell if the animals
have gotten indoors
and he is um he's well he's a mid-sized
animal control man and he can handle
anything from you know i'm going to go
on from mouse to bobcat style
that includes woodpecker flying squirrel
deer hornet beaver coyote
skunk bats and more
that's this man his company is titled
hawk predator and wildlife control
he has been in the game for a while
since he was a child and animals were
bothering him
and now he bothers them he's the dog the
bounty hunter
of mid-sized animal
za animals ladies and gentlemen mr
marty voyers
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
if you're hunting um if you're hunting
like vermin do you need
energy drink i drink a lot of coffee
do you i drink mountain dew dot mountain
dew okay yeah
i'm on a no card kick i've lost i went
from 260 down to
238 two days ago so i'm trying to get
some weight back off
oh really yeah and what are you leaning
up for the hunt animal
oh just to i don't to get rid of that
oh see oh it's kind of hard to get
through a crawl space and through an
attic door if you're
big as hell every space the damn crawl
space when you're big i guess
um do we um is this i mean do you cut
are you cussing out i don't know we can
say whatever you want okay yeah no
i don't want to no i appreciate it man i
don't want to say something i shouldn't
say
oh yeah the only things i don't say in
here usually are
i don't say i guess
i don't say the n word i don't say like
uh f-a-g-g-o-t i don't say that
and i don't say i don't say like a lot
of british curse words like c-u-n-t
i don't say that i don't say p-u-s-s-y
i don't say all right like lady i don't
say stuff
i don't i don't okay yeah but anything
else is good
um or it's fine you know it's not good
but it is whatever you want it to be
i've watched some of your i've tried to
study some of your talk
well i don't know if that's good or not
man i mean all of it's a little bit
different you know i think
you know first of all i appreciate you
coming in how do you say your name so i
know what i'm saying marty
okay voyeurs voyeurs thank you this
is more than one peeping tom oh yeah
voyeurs
you have a warrior or you have a voyeurs
oh yeah we had voyagers usually where
i'm from we had uh
i remember we had to if you wanted to if
you wanted to go out tom and her p
time and they called it you had to get a
ladder from a guy because
nobody around us had a ladder so we go
over there and say look wednesday
you know about 4 35 p.m we want that
ladder
you know and uh and we get out there and
peeping time and i actually
i enjoy i mean as a kid it was you know
what is that you're doing this
this i'm from louisiana louisiana okay
so it reminded me of uh
we didn't have cable for a while so i
know you'd go over to some people's
house and it was like watching
it was like watching television almost
you know the windows even shaped like a
dang television
so i remember sitting out there and just
you know you know
the show isn't that good this is a
family eating damn you know tv dinners
and stuff but it was still
local programming i guess but that's
just a way to i mean i don't like to say
that my dad cringes when i do that but
for somebody didn't know how to
pronounce my name it's
warriors voyeurs it's french so there
you go yeah
and now that's the only thing i just i
mean on the youth is i mean
i just don't like because some people
don't want to talk about i say oh yeah
if they're like are you going to
relocate them like well i'm going to
take care of them that's yeah no i i
make the customer feel good
well some animals you gotta have to you
relocate them to the lord
you know what i'm saying like that's how
i kind of see it you know some of them
it's
that's life you know well i mean look
it's an interesting job you have so
friend your name is french i guess and
the french are notorious
fur trappers aren't they is that true or
not i guess they're fur trappers there
do you feel that in your genetics ever
well i'm a fur i'm out trap
oh you do oh yeah now i sent i sent them
guys a ton of picks i run a winter
trap line predator trap line this year i
ended up with 66 coyotes
and four bobcats and a lot of other
miscellaneous animals foxes
and raccoons but i do that every year in
the wintertime starting in november
to february 28th it's it's for i'm slow
my business is slow in the winter
and my farming is none in the winter
just the fact of feeding cattle
and a fur trap and i go and that helps
my business and i do a lot in the winter
time i'll do it for free you know i tell
if you've got coyote problems i'll come
take care of your coyotes and i'll do it
for
free okay so when you're dealing with a
coyote
get take me through that process so
somebody calls you and says hey bucko we
got a coyote out here we got something
what's the usual complaint if they don't
know that it's a coyote that it's
getting their uh they have something
killing their calves okay
which more than likely it's usually
something the calf dies and the coyote
is seen eating on it or tracks and he
gets to blame
oh damn but i mean they will they'll get
a newborn they'll get a calf like
al's having it like that she's
defenseless i didn't mean to
she's defenseless when it's coming out
of her uh-huh and they'll
sometimes they'll grab it then she can't
she can't
fight defend them and they'll eat that
after birth but they'll come after a
sick no nature they'll come after
something sick
you know if it's injured or sick they'll
come after it
but uh you know i get a lot of calls for
that raid chicken houses chicken coops
or their ducks missing
oh yeah that's just like on that cartoon
remember that um
was in that cartoon where it was always
in the hen house i'm trying to think of
what it was that one with the big
rooster all right you know what i'm
talking about a little bit yeah the
the big had the little trick he had to
bit the i said
yeah yeah that guy had a little the
little yeah yeah yeah
you're running around a little little
itty bitty chicken these fellas right
here
yeah fall corn leg horns dude and
falcorn lego and i think that's dutch
that name
but yeah he was in new uh yeah he always
had something right here
yeah with something breaking in so for
cayo so so
that's fascinating so we're talking to
mr voyeurs here and you deal with all
types of basically animalia that are
problems right
yes sir okay and so i want to get
immediately back into that coyote
question because that's just
so is it kind of crazy to think that
they'll attack during the birth huh
yeah they'll they'll go after a cow or
an animal deer
cow they're having they're young they're
defenseless and they'll
they'll try to go after them the ending
cases um deer
the fawn that's one of their main
predators is coyote one of
the for the mortality rate for a baby
deer it's upon
his coyotes um they'll get the animals
when they're weak
sick and just kind of mother nature help
help them clean up
no they'll get one when it's sick sick
take it out
and do you see that as like it's almost
like that's like mother nature doing or
do you feel like that that's like damn
it's kind of cheating or do you feel
like that's kind of just the way that
mother nature works
i mean you have something that's like
i'm not gonna make it through the winter
it's gonna starve to death mother
nature's taking out something to feed
the other and it's not going to suffer
it's it's mother nature
yeah but i mean it's sometimes mother
nature's cruel
she's very cruel sometimes but she is
she's really stepmother nature almost
yeah you know there you go i feel like
you know i mean
i love my stepmoms i got a great stamp
mom so
yeah i mean i've got a great mother and
a great stepmom oh you do oh yeah oh you
oh your dad picked some good ones huh oh
yeah i love my parents they're the best
they raised me up good they're the best
so now did you were you into dealing
with animals at
a young age because if you're a real
animal man then you
i'm guessing you really got into animal
you're pretty young huh
my grandfather got me into trapping when
i grew up on grew up going over the farm
every weekend when i was a youngster and
he got me in a trap in groundhogs
getting rid of the groundhogs
and started trapping there and just
worked my way up over the years and he
bought me my first traps at the feed
store and
it just worked up over time and what
kind of traps were those first traps
uh my first traps were one and a half um
leg holes
like foot traps bring that up sean
i want to see what that looks like so we
got an idea of it
so now tell me how this thing works here
how does this kind of trap work
uh [ __ ] it's a spring trap you when
you compress the sides of whichever one
you're look we're looking at you can
press the sides of it and it's got a
latch at a pan
and when you get when you latch the pan
and then you'll cover it up by bed the
track you bed the trap down cover it up
sometimes i
make a bait hole sometimes i don't or
it's a walk-through set
and or if it's groundhog you know i
place it down in the in the den for the
groundhog when i don't use that method
in my business but growing up trapping
that's how i got rid of the groundhogs
and now why would you do uh so so when
you say bedding you put like a leaves
and stuff over some kind of camera
and in essence i i bed to trap down to
where they don't see it okay kind of dig
out you kind of dig out a hole you
and you place the trap down covered up
to where they walk in they don't see it
but they step on it and they're going
after like if
it's a coyote or a predator i use a bait
hole which i'll
make a dig a little hole in the ground
and put a lure or commercial lure bait
in it so
the coyote's concentrating on that and
we'll dig it out
and then get the trap while he's working
the set going after the bait
okay so what kind of bait do you use for
so for groundhog you won't use a bait
you'll kind of just wait for their
weight to hit it well i mean if you
loot now i don't in my younger when i
was a kid i'd use a leg hole trap but if
i'm at a customer's house
can't really use a a foothold trap in
somebody's front yard y'all i have a
we use a good cage as i use as a
comstock
uh cage a double door cage and i'll set
it
bet it and set it in front of the hole
and make a deposit to where when the
groundhog comes out he has to go in that
trap
he has no option but to go in there to
get outside so that way
i can say i catch three groundhogs and
we don't catch anything for a week
i can say there's no more groundhogs in
that hole and then we can seal the hole
up
and we're done so this trap right here
this is a single door trap you said yes
sir
well it's double door single to orbit
comstock it's one of my favorite traps
one of the
most popular traps with the white
nuisance wildlife operator
so that's just pretty basic it looks
like it has like kind of this uh like
almost a teeter-totter door where once
you go through it it just closes back
and you yeah
it's spring loaded door on it and it's
got the triggers in the middle so when
raccoon groundhog comes through he bit
he hits those triggers in the middle and
it's a spring-loaded door
and it's not like a tractor supply cage
trap it's spring loaded it goes down it
goes down
hard enough to worry if one gets caught
in it could kill it underneath of it it
could
it could get it wow okay and so what
animal honestly when you see an
animal that and you trap one which one
is seem like the happiest to get trapped
is there any that's like thank god for
getting me out of this thing oh no never
very happy
really no um because someone i wonder
sometimes if there's animals out there
that are ready to be domesticated
they're just like please
god come and somebody take me out of
this damn
food chain you know because i'm sure for
some animals it is just
it's a it's a dirty world out there
probably the most laid-back creature
that we trap the dye trap is probably
opossum
wise i mean it'll you come up to it if
it's in a cage it'll be
curled up asleep usually playing possum
or if it's any
i'll have them get into my uh trap when
i'm predator trapping though
and you can catch anything in these
traps no anything um
a possum's a scavenger them ground
buzzards what i call they
they'll eat anything dead or whatever on
the ground oh yeah forest shrimp they
call them sometimes
yeah and they'll i mean i've had them i
mean it sounds nasty
the dead cow i'll set sometimes around
it and i've seen them cut they'll go in
they'll eat their way inside of the cow
and how do they get in through like the
butt
really yeah through the through the rear
end yeah they eat their way right in i
mean it's kind of gross but
damn when you deal with i mean when you
deal with the i mean do it it doesn't
really bother you but that's i raise
cattle too i've been around cattle all
my life that's
that's just part of mother nature when
you my the old way we did it you know
you dragged a cow to the holler and let
mother nature
consume it yeah get back give back to
her let her consume you
know now you should take it you know
really to the landfill but
we usually have a holler or dig a hole
with loader maybe
tractor loader and bury it cover it up
wow but they're one
back to opossum when you get them
they're the most docile i mean
i can you can catch them i can pick them
up and hold them they're mainly
their main defense is they they snarl
which um
they show those teeth don't they yeah
it's a lot of them call them grinners
so right before you hit them right
before they get run over they grin real
big at you because that's their main
defense and they just grin and hiss at
you
to scare you away oh damn next girl
can't fight or dude
but they can't defend themselves anyway
and that's what and they are actually
marsupial
marsupial they're i mean they're rather
cool they have the pouch like a kangaroo
i mean they're a really neat
animal wow so so uh uh they have
the pouch can you bring up that pouch
sean so they have the pouch it's uh
i didn't know that um that they had that
yeah yes sir
yep they carry their they carry their
young in the pouch and now can you
get like is there like uh do you know
how many they could fit in there
no i i mean i did litter probably five
or six about an average litter
okay but i mean they they'll stay in
there whether so till they get so big
nate you know
it's obviously too big then they'll stay
with her right on her back like you got
the pictures
okay but they're i mean they're the mo
they're a pretty gentle creature
other than no raccoon not happy to see
you
coyote's not very happy even the
groundhog's not happy no really they'll
they'll chatter their teeth they'll grab
they'll bite their teeth at you dude
i know just like a little noise try to
scare you that's their defense that's
everything the skunk sprays uh
raccoons just mean they'll just come
after you
now tell me this sir is the um
what is a vermin how do you get upgraded
to vermin
you know what i'm saying is they're like
a is there like a
you know some rural kind of courtroom or
like you're a damn vermin now buck
like do they if something causes enough
problems is it then a vermin when does
it go from pest to vermin to
when did it swamp thing or whatever
house when you know raccoons are
i mean they don't bother you in in
nature you know you you see raccoons all
the time in the road or running around
they're not a pest until they make their
way in your house they get in your attic
to go through your soffit or chimney or
whatever and get into your attic your
house
have their babies um they
you know the feces everywhere uh
raccoons use a toy
use a toy they make they use the
bathroom like a cat in the same place
oh really so if you've got raccoons have
been in there for quite a while
you have quite a mess so if you see a
bunch of [ __ ] duty somewhere that's
really
you that's a giveaway real science yeah
oh yeah new oh i'll open up i had
i've opened up attic doors and had it
dumped right on me before the doors
swing down and it's
you're always opening your duck like
real easy to make sure
there's not going to be because that's
usually you know the bat guano or
raccoon feast is going to be right there
on top attic door also
like a surprise party yeah oh yeah
definitely be surprised you get that
dumped out too not what you want to do
i had a bad attack me i was trying to
make out with a girl i was about 14 in
an addict
and uh and i don't know if this bat knew
her or what but that thing like came
after me
boy i think it came out that might have
been
you know if her dad had passed and this
was it was a spirit
yeah or something yeah come back as a
damn bad boy
but this thing did not want me putting
my fangs in her neck that's for sure
you were just in his house you were
invading his area i probably was yeah
you know we wandered up into an attic of
a semi uh not abandoned house but a
house that hadn't even been built yet so
pre-abandonment um
now raccoons though get the they really
i feel like kind of get the
they get looked at i feel like as mother
nature's kind of hit man a little bit
they really have come into their own as
being just
burglars you know like i think every
time you see them they look so
guilty they look like they they're they
call them a banter abandons they that
kind of a mask on them
i mean they when they see our houses or
your house they just see a tree
they see you know every you know the
neighborhoods and subdivisions are
tearing down more woods and more
environment to
build the houses so they're running out
of places and they don't have really
their
main predators man wow and so they they
when they look at your house just like
any of these animals they just see a
they just see a big tree a funny looking
tree you know they can climb right up
the siding right up a down spout
and they'll find a way in and they'll
make they'll make your home their home
so they just see their how your house is
a tree really that's yeah i mean that's
what they see it is you know just
just a different type of structure they
want to be the
the female raccoons they want to be up
high they want you know
if they're not like a cavity of a tree
it's where they know would be in the
nature
because they want it they want to be up
high so when they have their young
they're away from predators
they're away from things that could hurt
their babies one of their main
one their main concerns when they're
having their babies is male raccoons
another one of mother nature's things
is a male raccoon will search out to
female and kill those babies
to make her come into heat again which
is mother nature
another cruel way of mother nature it's
it's just a cycle just it's just mother
nature
and so the mama raccoons or sow raccoons
that we come they'll they'll go
they get hide up in the attics and
that's they'll make their dens trying to
keep away from everything else
and the male raccoons so even there
could it even be the own male that
knocked them up
i mean it could be i don't know my god
dude
just sound like a damn john grisham i
mean it it's possible some of the
one technique that we use um eviction
fluid
which is mainly raccoon piss and
you can take it i'm not a big fan of it
because i like to catch the raccoon and
remove it no i've removed it out of your
house
but you can take eviction fluid and put
around their entry hole and in the attic
and the female raccoon will think
there's a male present
and take her babies and shy down there
okay so you mean if you want to get her
out of that yeah some some places they
if you use like all humane you know no
trapping
they can use eviction fluid and that
that some that can make the female think
there's a male present and she'll get
her babies and get out
but you still have there's a raccoon
there right it's going to go somewhere
else it's going to be somebody else's
problem
i mean i like to trap them and get rid
of it that way i can tell the customer
hey we got
i've got mama i got five kits out of
your attic and
sealed up and we're good to go then we
got yeah we got the problem solved
otherwise you just
once you put that piss down there you
they're just looking they're you just
you're scaring them off you don't know
where you're scaring them to
yeah they haven't really solved the
problem they can they'll either leave or
they'll just go even deeper
you just carrying the one yeah you
haven't really solved the problem now
what about this uh
i want to get back a little bit to this
i mean it's almost like a
shakespeare story that the so the the
female
can have children have babies raccoon
can have babies and a man raccoon
will come and kill the babies while
they're being born
well after she has after she has them
will the male raccoon eat them or just
kill them
he usually just kills them okay kill him
and then kill him just so the female
will go back in the heat so then he can
get laid basically
yeah i mean yeah you could put it that i
mean it's not the only all
a lot of animals do it uh lions you know
the they'll kill the cubs
you know the other animals like it'll
kill their offspring or
the offspring it just hurts me man to
make her to make him come back in the
heat so that's
it just hurts my feelings i mean that
that's not i i don't come across it very
often but i mean
i've found it where i'll come do an
attic inspection
and just find a bloodbath you know just
a little young
i mean they'll catch i mean size of the
the popcan
and just be ripped open just no horrible
where the male raccoons come in and kill
them all
right i mean it happens you don't see it
very often which i don't see it very
often
it's like the people may it's like the
first forest eight kind of
yeah you know it's something like i said
mother nature's cool sometimes it's just
you know the little man is who you want
you want that little man if you want a
baby
if you want something coming out of your
body you want it to be the little man
hell if you want something going into
your body you almost want it to be the
little man or
you know not too big of a man and that's
what i'm talking about mint
mobile if you're tired of getting ripped
off by
big wireless providers
well that's why you need mint mobile
mint mobile offers
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month 15
buckaroos a month and i thought well
what's the catch meant mobile
but after speaking with them and
actually after using their service
you're going to be shocked
you're going to be surprised but i tried
meant mobile
and the secret sauce is that they're the
first company to sell
wireless service online only
that's right by cutting out the retail
stores there's no crazy overhead
costs that's how ment mobile does it
that's how they save you money
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 bucks
a month delivered on the nation's
largest 5g
network if you're not 100 satisfied mint
mobile has you covered
with their 7 day money back guarantee to
get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and to get the
plan shipped to your door for
free for free go to mintmobile.com
t-h-e-o that's mint mobile.com
theo cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month at mintmobile.com
t-h-e-o
oh ah if you're gonna die baby
die a liquid death you know today's
episode is brought to you by
grub hub perks
we eat we can't help but eat we're
eaters
if you see somebody they're eating
probably or they've eaten recently
or they're planning on eating isn't that
fascinating
every person you will come across today
or have
or have come in contact with has
recently dined or is considering dining
hmm well if you're going to be spending
that money dining
why not get rewarded for it get
deals on the food you love with grub hub
perks grubhub has all the food you love
from all your favorite local restaurants
eat local
grubhub food delivery
its value with the food you get the
perks
get the perks grubhub what you love
take a break from cooking what are you
cooking you're no chef
your name's diane quit cooking
get perks on pizza tacos sushi and more
anything all the time get the perks try
something new with grubhub and all the
local restaurants in your area
try all the cuisines get the food you
love with perks from grubhub grub
what you love now here's a question that
came in from some fellow right here
who's probably out of work
but also uh seemed like a decent fella
right here here we go
hey theo i'm noah coming at you from
london england
huge fan uh i've got a question for the
real life wildlife control man
which is a question that theo actually
brought up on one of the joe rogan
episodes was that
how are these raccoons not a bigger
problem i mean you
you must deal with that you're on the
front line of this stuff so
tell us what's going on with these
raccoons
gang brother yeah yeah how are they not
a bigger problem it seems like they're
after sex you're saying they're doing
sex in the attic and they're
um you know they're willing to kill
children that get sex
and they're you know they're obviously
breaking into people's homes like
i see them in the recycling bin
constantly or i see music in the trash
and i'll see
you ever see that one weird raccoon
that's in the recycling bin it's like
what is he he's like he's reading in
there or something you know
but i'll see the ones that you know it's
like you'll go out at night here's what
i find fascinating you'll go out to a
rat you'll drive to a neighborhood
in a peaceful regular looking
neighborhood everything seems normal
and it's only three or four trees in the
dang neighborhood it wouldn't
if if you if you asked everybody all day
is there any raccoons in this
neighborhood
people put zero on the form and you come
by at about dang
12 40 i feel like or 11 15 p.m
and you'll see them in little groups of
three just cruising along man
it's like they they can hide so i mean
they hide right before your damn eyes it
seems like
so how are they not a bigger problem and
what kind of problem are they these
raccoons and you can be honest with me i
mean they're
they're my raccoon my raccoons every
year
through my business it's getting bigger
and bigger yeah i mean more it's getting
to be more and more of a problem
i knew it like the more we build and go
into the
farmland we're taking out their habitat
they're like i said
the only natural real predator is man is
a car
and disease which they get overcrowded
like anything they'll get disease will
get in them
distemper or they get rabies and they'll
kill some of them off
but they are i mean a lot of people have
them and don't know they have them
really you know you might you know if
you're in a house you might hear
something every once in a while and
they're like oh that's just
raccoon no big deal they don't come in
here and bother me in my living room
because i'll be in houses it'll in
addicts oh we just started hearing it
last week and it's obvious they've had
it for years
wow just some people just don't know it
i mean they're sneaky
they're sometimes quiet you got the
insulation in your attic and
they don't make a whole lot of noise you
know or you overlook it as something
else or
just don't want to know what just don't
want to know what it is
and are they flame retardant raccoons
can they are they are flammable animals
you know what i'm saying like they
they're their skin is so thick it seems
like they wouldn't be
in an attic it just seemed like a good
place for fire you know or something
like that i mean
they're actually they're very tough
creatures i've had um
i did had a one particular job this
spring early spring
or late winter and it took as a month
and three days before i caught four
raccoons have an attic
in a month and three days the final
raccoon came out
and what was he doing just hands up and
denying yeah they were juvenile
young raccoons last year's raccoons just
denning
and just they're trap shy and won't you
know
they won't they won't come out i mean in
the summertime it's not unusual to have
a raccoon go
a week maybe two weeks in the summer and
an attic could be 140 degrees
i mean they're tough creatures stay in
there no food or water
no sometimes they can get water your air
conditioning will have condensation pan
they'll sip off that bastard they can
get a little bit of water off that snake
they're just so damn sneaky that's what
gets me you know they're just the damn
they're the real andy dew friends of the
damn animal kingdom
you know what i'm saying they're wild
man is there any animal as
sneaky as a raccoon i mean let's put the
crown on the prince brother is there any
animal
as sneaky as a dang raccoon um
i gotta say bobcats there you go that's
i mean it's i don't get the calls no
for you know like they don't invade your
homes like a raccoon does but they're
they got to be pretty sneaky i mean i
would they're pretty sneaky um
rats i do a lot of rat work oh yeah they
can be a pretty sneaky so do i brother
they they're hard to get and they're
they're sometimes they're pretty big
challenge to get the rats they're pretty
sneaky they'll
they don't like change and you know you
mess with them they'll change their
routes and
where they come in and they're a sneaky
animal they're all kind of sneaky
but those come to mind as being the most
sneaky to me
i mean do you look at it as a
competition when you wake up in the
morning do you kind of look at it as
like you
like i kind of wonder how you envision
your position in the world i mean
do you look at it as like you're
kind of like the like that your help
that you're against the animals it's you
against them do you look at it as you're
just helping people
like just kind of what's the vibe that
you have to take on each day to really
get out there and
and solve some of these animal issues
that are in the world i love animals
oh you love them we i mean i love you
guys i love my work i love animals
you know i love working with them
getting to handle them we've got lots of
pets i mean i'm an animal lover
but i like helping people and
satisfaction
you know somebody's got somebody has a
house and they have a large
colony of bats and when i can go in and
seal that house up and
evict those bats get rid of them and do
and clean up their attic
like it was brand new i mean that's
that's some satisfaction yeah i could
see that back and say hey
i took care of this i mean it's it's
different than saying like well
you know you sold a new album or you
sold a new car
or signed a new deal said yeah i got rid
of those bats yeah i mean it's
it's satisfactory it's kind of a
different and it's each his own
it's kind of a different satisfaction
but i mean
it's very satisfying if i didn't love it
i wouldn't do it yeah i mean
i love them i love getting every morning
to something different it's something
new ever
it may be the same thing but it's
something
no raccoon job no bat job nothing is the
same it's always a little bit different
a little bit different scenario or what
how you have to set up on it or what
happens or
it's all a little bit there it's all a
challenge sometimes it's very
challenging
tell me about it take me on a call for
something where you
like i just had a vision of you like
walking through the zoo just kind of
looking at the animals being like i
could do all of this you know
kind of that's kind of clint eastwood if
you would you know i mean we
um you ever we go through the cincinnati
zoo
a couple years back and i was you know
like that the raccoons or something i'm
like oh yeah like the river riders i'm
like yeah i've done
i like otter jobs you know those are
those are everybody seasoned with loving
crap i mean they are loving creatures
very neat and pretty but they'll uh
come in if they can find your pond or
lake they'll wipe out your fish
no water oh yeah and so but they do the
tricks they do the tricks that make you
think they're being good
yeah they're cute but they're just there
for your fish oh i mean they're they're
you know they can be
that's what they're cute until they
start taking away
something and then they're a pest like
you said then they're cute
oh they're cute and cuddly then they
start until the tuna's gone in there
yeah
the tuna's gone and then they they gotta
go you know then they're then they're a
pass then the people don't like and they
gotta go
now why does an otter look so cute you
think to us because they do those tricks
i've seen them do the tricks in the zoo
you know you get by the zoo cage or the
water zoo
and you'll see them do those tricks and
it makes me feel like oh man they're
yeah
they're lovely they're this and that but
you don't notice the two otters in the
back
beating the [ __ ] out of a carp you know
what i'm saying like you know what i'm
saying you don't notice the hit you know
what i'm saying you don't notice the
other side
of the uh of the aluminum you know i
mean
they look cute they're mercury yeah they
look so they groom themselves
that does and when they do that you know
it looks cute oh look at you know if
he's
they're grooming themselves and they're
always where their hair they're oily to
where it helps them shed the water oh
yeah i think they just make them look so
cute
oh yeah they got this summer they look
like they got their hair dyed for the
summer they're ready to kind of you know
like they're going to the beach like
they're going to be in damn destiny
all summer i mean it's like a baby
raccoon i mean i handle lots of babies
and they're so cute and cuddly but they
grow up to be big raccoons
and then they can be very destructive
same way as a little baby groundhog's
cute and cuddly looking
but they're gonna grow up to dig
underneath their house and you know dig
underneath your foundation cause it to
settle and crack
i mean they're all cut they're all cute
until they
destroy something and then they're a
pest i got it and then there's guys like
me that got to come in and take care of
them okay so now that's it so now we're
seeing kind of the evolution from
them just being an animal to them
becoming a past they become a pest when
they
are bothering you yeah when they're
bothering something
when they're causing some disruption in
our world now
is it kind of weird because we're really
causing a disruption in their world
we're the one invading their territory
yeah like you buy a piece of land it's
like
you know it's not like you get to go to
the courthouse and nine groundhogs get
to show up and be like yeah what's the
deal i mean
you buy a farm they level it out and
build subdivisions those groundhogs are
still there
right and they're gonna come up to your
front porch under your bushes
up against your barn or your garage and
they're going to dig their holes
because you're in their world that's
their area
and then that and then they're cute and
cuddly and not really a big harm when
they're out in nature other than the cow
or horse
you know stepping in a hole maybe
breaking their leg something or
you know something like that but then
when they invade your house
then they're a pest and then they got to
go most people don't ever encounter
something like that until they become at
best
right right yeah cause you don't notice
it really yeah they're neat oh look at
the groundhog in the neighbor's yard
over there
and then next summer when that groundhog
had babies and some of their babies come
to your house
or grown start digging then it's not
cute anymore then they then they call us
it is interesting how animals go from
that there's that real fine line from
cute to pests didn't there yeah
is that real fine line baby raccoons
they're adorable i mean they're
well they're so cute my grandmother
didn't really like me and uh whenever
she
died or uh she was still alive but
we we didn't get along well but um the
lady i remember this lady told me one
time my grandma didn't like me this is
her friend
her friend told me that and her friend
had a raccoon on him which told me
her friend kept a raccoon as a pet do
you see a lot of people
keeping animals and i remember thinking
well sh
oh yeah anyway i don't know i told you
that but i remember just thinking well
what now why did my grandmother even
have this lady as a friend who has a
damn raccoon why is this lady her friend
but she doesn't like me that's what i'm
thinking
okay but anyway um you see people
starting to take on
animals where it seems a little bit like
it's more about them than it is about
the animal
you know it's a little bit more status
yeah there's something going on
sometimes they're trying to have a
little bootleg
ass noah's ark in their bathtub or
something have you run into some stuff
like that where somebody calls you is
like hey look buddy you know like
i had a small you know like i had a
small dream of doing a little bit of
doctor doolittle [ __ ] in the garage
and suddenly things have gotten out of
control had a couple
it mainly happens on like a rental
property where somebody's had a
pet raccoon okay so it starts with right
so it's usually raccoons yeah
it's usually a raccoon sometimes
squirrels they know somebody finds a
young
raccoon oh yeah no kid something happens
they find a little young raccoon not
scared of humans and they take it and
they try to make it a pet which i mean
is what do they do
i don't know about tennessee's laws
because i'm not licensed here but
in in kentucky it's it's against the law
to keep to have a pet any
animal it's indigenous to the state deer
raccoon dirt no
okay so take me back home and let's
let's slow that down for me and for our
listeners but so what does that mean any
animal that's indigenous well i mean
anything
any animal it's it's a common animal in
the state
no raccoon possum fox squirrel
you cannot have those as pets yeah
you're not allowed do you're not allowed
to keep the wildlife as a pet
even it's like rehabilitating even if
you think you're doing you're not
you're not supposed to not saying
they're going to come get you right but
but there's some laws i mean they do you
know i'm i'm i have some
conservation officer friends and they do
receive calls and complaints about
people
pet deer pet raccoons and you i mean
they're still
a wild animal damn the raccoons they can
be
i mean you can have a raccoon and if you
if you google it
they'll they'll turn you know a raccoon
might be fine for a couple years
and then they've turned and attacked
children toddlers babies in their sleep
i mean they
they're still a wild animal just you
know so what usually like how do people
first let me get into
if people have a raccoon what do they
try to do to have it really be part of
their little life like i see sometimes
they'll put a little diaper on it or
they'll put a damn little
uh necklace on it or something you see
them maybe get a little bit of a
you know i've seen one had a little even
somebody made it a little damn
amulet thing for its wrist you know i'm
saying like you see people really try
and
make them human in some way have you
come into somebody
ever you know if you had to go and if
you find something that's wearing a damn
you know uh
izzod shirt or something you know have
you ever found anything like that where
somebody's got a damn homemade outfit
you know got some
you know little baby uh birkenstocks on
a damn uh
on a raccoon or anything like that no i
mean i've run across people with pet
raccoons
that's cool i mean they that's their
prerogative they got them dressed up or
not
no they i mean they'll have i've seen
them with collars on them you know
little decorative collars but not
dressed i mean if you put something on a
raccoon this is gonna pull it off
i mean they're they're pretty they're
pretty they're very smart animals
they're gonna pull it off i mean
i've seen people pet squirrels you get
them as a baby
i mean they're but they're still a wild
animal and do any so is there a is there
something you can do
to keep it domesticated so it doesn't
turn wild again
i mean everything can turn i mean i
don't personally know i've known i've
raised a few deer up for a
spot a little bit of time as
i had one that we that would that got on
the job and i kept it for a while
and then it turned well i took it to the
rehabilitator
you know i get doe or a phone call baby
deer get abandoned
i mean like on a deer i'm we're getting
off the subject here
the the worst thing like people say i
found a baby deer
is mama when she takes her when she has
her baby she'll place it away from her
to keep she keeps away from it as much
as she can not to put any scent on it
that way the predator won't find it so
when she beds the baby deer down
she'll put it down and she'll leave and
go away from him and she's just a couple
hundred yards away
but that way if something comes it don't
get her baby and people
oh here's an abandoned deer oh i'm gonna
help it i'm gonna say once you touch it
it's done she's not gonna take that
baby back that's got your human scent on
it and then they'll call they'll
try to raise it themselves or they'll
call me or call a game warden
and then we take them you know i've kept
them for several weeks you know just
getting them back on their feet bottle
feeding them and then take them to a
rehabber
in which they're a licensed rehabber and
they raise them up they'll raise them up
to where they can survive on their own
and release them back in the wild
okay and they do that of all i mean they
do it with all animals
i mean baby raccoons we can take them to
a rehabber
and they can rate they'll bottle feed
them raise them up and release them back
into the wild
okay okay uh let's get a question that
came in from
one of our uh listeners here we got a
lot of great listeners
on this podcast and real grateful for
that and uh here's a man right here that
had a question about something
decent man what up theo what up nick
what up animal police man i got a
question for you guys
what's hair what's harder to catch in
the streets one of these
young cats or one of them dog dogs out
there
it's harder to catch out on the streets
when you're working by the way theo
thank you for that gang merch just came
in oh man
official that new addition
with the hit her in the front baby
people make a lot of bootleg merchandise
and sell it and that's bootleg brother
sorry that's unbelievably bootleg dear
god
uh so that's a good question man
that that is a that's a good question um
a lot of
wildlife operators will not touch a cat
okay we
don't normally ever fourth in a canine
because you have dog pound
uh dog warden but there's no cat warden
oh okay and i i myself i do cat work i
do feral cat work
oh you do cat work oh you do wear some
cat work be honest you do cat work yeah
i do feral cat work
okay i'm just saying now hold on who's
feral cat
just a while not not a domesticated
domesticated it's just a cat that's
running wild
that you can't get close to um i'm sure
if you drive around i mean
most towns and cities you're driving
you'll see cats running everywhere oh
yeah those are
just they just scavenge off whatever
they can find
you can't touch them they're just wild
oh dude i grew up in the stray animal
belt man we had cats everywhere we had
animals passing through town we had damn
parakeet i mean everything came through
town
groups of them you know i remember one
summer seen about 40 cats out there
well that's i mean you get a oh for
instance like a townhome
community and they'll go from one or two
cats and you know
little old ladies feeding them she feels
sorry for him to 60 70 cats and they
attack her while she sleeps well
well a couple of female cats they get
bred they have kittens within you know
less than a year
those kittens will breed and then
another year those kittens from those
kittens will breed
so it's like this story you can go
really then you got all these cats that
are living they're going to get diseased
because there's so many of them
they get all over your cars crap all and
pee all around your bushes and stinks
and then but you can't get close to them
so that's when they they get up you know
i'll do
fair i'm not going to turn down work i
try to help my community
you know sometimes it's hard you know
trying to find homes for them
some you know have to struggle sometimes
to find shelters that'll take the cat
and when you pick them up you put them
in the back seat or front seat where do
you put them in the back of the truck
oh really oh yeah i don't know a feral
cat can be very mean
because they i mean they'll they'll
reach right through that cage you know
if it's big enough they'll try to
reach through there a scratch from a cat
can
get very i mean can get infected because
all all that dirt
and stuff on their nails when they
scratch you and you
some of them caught uh cats cats cat
scratch
fever yeah we should play that at the
library i i've had scratch been
scratched by cats trying to handle them
with my big gloves on
and they'll get real infected i mean
they'll get you got it that was a song
too
whose song was that bring that up
yeah play a little bit of that man
that's ted nugget
so when you hear this i bet this you
should play this this should be your
dang alarm
when you wake up yeah huh but they can
i mean i i could go to a job like that
and maybe capture 30 cats
i mean no
with any wildlife you got to be careful
wear proper ppe
right you know when i full with the cats
i wear bike proof gloves that come up to
about my elbows that way they can't
scratch me i don't
you know i don't want to get full of
getting infected and have to nurse the
wound you know it's hard enough doing my
work anyway
but we don't do any dogs no i just
that's getting too
i'll do cats you know if i do a cat job
you know it has to be a certain
you know just i won't like if you just
pissed at the neighbor's cat i'm not
gonna come do that oh i wouldn't do that
yeah i mean i
used to piss around my bed when i was
growing up though dude i'll tell you
this this is a true story
so growing up i was real scared right we
grew up in a pretty scary area
and uh i remember hearing when i was
young and i've talked about this a bunch
on this podcast but
i remember hearing when i was young if
if animals smell urine they won't come
by
you know that's what i remember hearing
so i was so scared i would pee or i
would stand on my bed at night and pee
around it in like a semi circle
so that no animals came to get me
because i was so scared of like
huh yeah i never got attacked by
anything you know or anything uh
indoors but yeah it's just crazy to
think that as a kid you know that you
have uh
you know just that you hear stuff like
that and and how to heart you can take
it as a child
when you say that there's no dog um
police i start to see that there's
probably some jurisdiction issues do you
ever run into jurisdiction issues where
the dog catcher
has got issues with you because you're
trying to
you know you're i don't do i don't do
any dogs and why not you can be honest
with me
i mean i just because it means
somebody's pet i mean there's not that
many so there's more emotion involved
in dogs i mean i'm just you're getting
too much even with the cats you know
i'll do a job and i'm like
you know this gonna be neighbors cats
yeah i can't know
usually a cat problem is it like a
shopping
or a restaurant you know the employees
are getting bombarded by all these stray
cats that are around the dumpsters
oh i'll tell you stuff like that now i
don't go into you know
betty betty in the neighborhood's got a
cat and she wants you to get rid of it
because she's pissed at the neighbor in
a turcat now i mean it's too much legal
issue there and
bad publicity right now that's a good
point too that's why you don't want to
get in there i mean
a lot of my friends they won't touch a
cat job just for that fact
i'm picky about my i get a lot like
factories
uh power plants will get no cats will
come in
people dump cats off they ride in your
vehicles up in the engine compartment
when it's cold
and then they multiply and they gotta go
i mean they're wasted you don't it's a
health risk
usually you drop them at the power plant
they're gonna go somehow yeah i'm saying
i feel like that's kind of
that you know a lot of people used to do
that they'd drop them off with the power
plant and let you know
and let you know let it happen you know
let it kind of work out that cat scratch
fever right there bro
but how about this so what i'm trying to
figure out is um
so when it comes to the domestic animals
that's not really your line of work
no how did you get from your your
grandfather gives you the trap and
you're trapping stuff around the way
how do you then get into the echelon
where you stay in that vein for most
your youth and childhood
and uh and then you just get into it as
a profession when did that start
well i grew up hunting fish and trapping
my grandfather
taught me everything and then i get into
the
job world work couple jobs and then i
worked for uh
my last one was for a rock mine close to
where i lit underground mine
and i still trapped you know honest you
know just little stuff
and somebody will call me hey i've got
groundhogs in my barn can you come get
rid of them
like yeah i could probably do that and i
come over and trap them they're like
well
here's 20 bucks or here's a six pack or
you know be nice no give me a little bit
of something oh yeah and
oh i've got this raccoon i heard your
you trap can you come get rid of it
then i started looking no i can make
money at this
i could do this for real no i started
reaching out looking on
facebook find another wildlife guys
um one of them it taught me a lot of
stuff my mentor ronnie vincent which is
about
uh 150 miles away from me and
he kind of took me under told me how you
know get me started what
you know just kind of get tips where new
guys get into the business
and just evolve from there went from
trapping loving to trap this
you got to be a trapper to do this you
just i mean you can't just go buy trash
you could go buy traps and do it but you
got to
know how to lure the animal in
what baits work best what areas they're
going to use to come
you know runways or travel away you got
to have a little bit of background in it
where it really helps
to to do that so it just evolved from
trapping as a kid
loving animals to wanting to change a
career
so i quit my other job as a minor
and was already farming so farming
full-time and then i started my wildlife
business
and so um so ronnie was you kind of
worked as an apprentice in some way
under you know ronnie just giving you a
lot of guide
like if i had a problem i'd call it i
was on the phone with him every day
he knew what was going on and it's like
man i've got this hat what's the best
way
no i can i can catch a squirrel outside
somewhere what's the best way to catch
it on a house you know and i
got to you know i had to take i had to
study and take my tests through the
state fish and wildlife to be a nuisance
control operator and
head to study guide and i bought a nukoa
which
is a an organization for the wildlife
operators
and some of their core online courses
and some of their books and literature
to just get more from animal trapping in
the wild to
adapt into your house okay right on the
difference from trapping a raccoon in
somebody's barn to
to making a positive set on a house and
it's in your soffit and you're
25 30 feet off the ground with the trap
upside down under the soffit will try to
screw it down and attach it to your
side of your house do you ever have to
like fingerprint or dust for prints or
do any kind of like
track like is there any detective type
style work you know
yeah um one thing that we use a lot now
is cameras
um i use a spy point cell cameras it
goes send the pictures through your cell
phone there's other ones uh
arlo cameras that do video and we use
that
i've got three going on jobs now i mean
we all use that to monitor
um say uh are they coming and going here
so i'll put that camera up
and now it'll send an alert to my phone
i know when that raccoon
is coming and going and they're motion
sensing well yeah it's motion motion
sensitive
another trick that we use that i've used
um if i suspect something's coming and
going don't really know what it is i'll
take flour
yeah put some flour down on a piece of
cardboard and when they step through
that they'll leave their tracks
we do that we yeah we do that for santa
you know yeah i had to see a static come
through yeah
and one time was my damn brother he'd
been drinking any damn came through
and he actually speaking of urinating on
stuff he urinated on something
um what type of animal has the most sex
out there i wonder when people think
there's a lot of animals you see a lot
of animals and
you'll see them with their children but
you don't hear about the sex a lot of
times
um is there a lot of animals where
animal the actual
mating becomes a problem for a homeowner
where
that is the issue a lot of times i mean
i don't think that's really an issue i
mean i've never i've never had somebody
call and say well
these raccoons keep having sex can you
come get rid of them i've never really
yeah
had that i mean but i mean could you see
it happening possibly
well it's all in the cover of dark i
mean there are nocturnal animals they
only come out at night
and that's something they're probably
not going to do in your front yard for
you
but you know what like yeah yeah that's
true yeah
but i mean i guess would they get into
the house to mate i guess would do
people
well they'll be mating a raccoon will
make they'll mate they won't go in the
house to mate
they made outdoors they'll mate
somewhere and you know when she comes in
the heat and she finds a suitor
and she accepts him and they mate and
then she'll seek out a den
place to have her babies which would be
your attic or under your house
okay yeah they don't they don't go in
your house to mate you know they're
gonna mate
she's going in her house to keep away
from that guy she don't want him back
she wants to keep away from him and
anything else that could hurt her babies
right it's like planned parenthood
almost a little bit kind of
some you know or something you get a
pamphlet for there let's get another
question that came in right here what do
we have showing that really some people
are inquiring
man do you feel okay i want to make sure
you feel comfortable do you yeah okay
good i'm loving it now okay good you're
good
good man yeah no this is all really cool
information man uh
just little pieces of it are just so
fascinating it's just like
things you just wouldn't think about so
let's keep going what do we got here we
got a young fella right here who's got
an animal
what's up theo what's up animal wrangler
uh this is cody from arkansas
i was just calling to ask uh what is
like the biggest injury
or anything that you've got from trying
to wrangle an animal
anyways uh thanks guys gang gang
yeah how violent is the game is it an
acl what happens out there is it carpal
tunnel what happens when you're dealing
with these animals my biggest injury is
i've had two ladders break on me that's
my biggest
injury wise it's put me in a hospital
for a little bit no not
nothing broke just i've had two ladders
fail when i go up and down
ladders i mean might be 30 times a day
for me and i'm small time
you know and that and you're going to
have an end you're going to have
something happen
um actual animals uh
have one happened last summer for this
nice lady is a church parsonage
in area where i work at and had raccoons
coming in her house
then through the attic normal spots in
the soffit so i catch the right she
calls me hey you've got a raccoon so i
come over
and she's out back and she's uh
it's the personage i guess it would have
been been the pastor's wife
or family and so i'm a talking to her
and she's asking me this question so i'm
telling her we're gonna put another trap
back up there ma'am and i have my sis
my assistant tim my one employee he was
already putting another trap back up
over the hole
and as i was talking to her i kind of
let my guard down i reached down and
grabbed the trap
i picked it up from the top i had it
sitting
horizontal up and straight up and down
and i grabbed the end of it and stuck my
finger
into the cage where for as long she
where she could find it and she grabbed
a hold of me
and needless to say i let out pretty
good scream and a few words i shouldn't
have in front of them
felt kind of bad really bad apologize
for it i mean
bled all over everywhere i mean it was a
pretty good wound
but i mean it's that i have uh uh i've
been vaccinated for rabies oh you have
yeah
well now so so so in that instance you
had already a raccoon in the cage
and you just put your hand too close to
it well i i stuck my hand
the so the cage is straight up and down
right and i'll put my hands through the
the end of it where the door
is there's nothing there so i'll just
put my fingers through the cage and pick
it up
right well i was talking to her and
looked away as i was reaching it
reaching for the cage and just wasn't
looking just
stupid mistakes stuck my fingers in
where she could get him she went right
after him
and didn't want to let go was to grab
and you know trying to get my finger in
me
they bare they rip their finger off i
mean really yeah they're pretty strong
you know i i've been [ __ ] hunting and
i've talked to [ __ ] hunters before
we don't have [ __ ] kill a dog a big boar
[ __ ] kill a dog
they're a bad animal now are they i
don't you definitely don't want them
biting your finger
i mean it bit right through my finger
now i mean it was still pretty painful
you don't want that we don't want to do
it at the preacher's house yeah
that's the wrong place to well at least
look at least there they can pray for
you baby boy
she was sympathetic she understood it
because she went got me some water to
wash it off and she's really nice she
understood
let's see what that animal looks like i
mean you can get him 25 30 pounds
wow oh look at him right there attacking
a hole gun
look at him fighting go back my god look
at them fighting
now now have you ever witnessed some
good animal fights and be honest there
i've seen i've had my dog i've been out
before my dog
get attacked by raccoon and they're
they're pretty i mean they're vicious
they won't let
a raccoon a bad raccoon will
instead of running he'll just lay up
rare up on his back lay down his back
and fight
oh yeah but that way he's got his back
covered on the ground
and fight yeah it's almost like they
teach mma to kind of do that
this episode is brought to you by modify
and the last website you'll ever need
yep it's the last website you will ever
need think about that think about a
website
and that's the only time you need to do
it because modify will take it
from there they're like a warm blanket
of comfort
once you get involved with them they
built my website
theovonne.com you don't have to do
anything
modify's last website plan features no
cost to build
no contract 45-day turnaround
unlimited revisions and support easy
editing tools
free redesigns satisfaction guaranteed
all for just 249 dollars a month yep
249 dollars a month it really seems to
be
good to be true can't take my
sight off of you yep
and they'll fix your logo up too that's
right to learn more
about the last website you'll ever need
visit
modify.com theo and get a 250
credit when you subscribe for your
world-class website
again that's modify with a
p-h-m-o-d-i-p-h-y
dot com slash theo these guys don't
f around gang
i'm going to let you know that the new
be good to yourself hoodies
are sold out but they'll be back in
stock next week
the original be good yourself hoodie is
back and in stock
now that's the green and yellow
summertime designs are coming soon
we also have the new get the hitter
merch you can check it out go to
theofonstore.com um
one other announcement um we
uh want you to nominate single moms if
you have a single mom you think uh
you know could use a little bit of help
don't let her know
don't take the fun out of it don't take
the fun out of it but let us know
and let us know why you think she could
use some help
send in a video to tpwproducer
gmail.com or go through theovan.com
there's a way to upload a video through
there
we have an initiative this year to uh
to be um in the wallets of some single
mothers out there so they can do
something fun with their kiddos
uh it's close to our heart and we know
that it's close to yours
um also send in funny videos from tick
tocks or anything you see that's wild
out in the universe
that's right go to theovonne.com and
submit it through the video site
say hey i want you guys to uh
to finesse about this or chat about this
and we will do it
all right now back to the show when i
was growing up
rabies was a big deal you know i mean it
was just
popular you would constantly hear about
it the fear of it what was going on
and then i get a text from somebody
maybe a year ago and they said rabies is
kind of making a comeback
have you heard of this yeah it's rabies
in
kentucky in my area of the state um
it's the it's gotten worse over the last
couple years
as in not i don't know of people cases
but animals
um getting tested and getting the rabies
at the
fox raccoon skunk
and coyotes are all in the rabies vector
and we have to euthanize
those now because there's such a high
number of rabies cases with them
now you roll up on one of these right
one of these
you know something that's rabid how do
you know out of the gate
um i got a call last week from a car
dealership at home
hey we got this raccoon or excuse me
excuse me it's skunk
they're getting animals make that bill's
a skunk they say oh look if the skunk
gets its nails done it's almost a damn
raccoon i'll tell you that in the middle
of the parking lot
at 12 o'clock in the afternoon and at
lunch time yeah
and it's walking around in circles it's
falling down
it's stumbling it's stomping which
what's that
something they do when they're
threatening they'll stomp their they'll
rear up and take their feet and stomp
the ground
it's basically like seeing like somebody
that's cracked out on drugs and it's
spraying it it's spraying some
it's spraying some scent oh yeah spray
it spraying its uh
essence which i call it it's skunk spray
and it's doing that
and i thought well it's it's it's
showing signs it's either got distemper
or rabbit damn and so
i come out and i end up i just i put my
gloves on i brought a cage put a cage
down over next to it and i took some six
foot tongs which is
like just big grabbers and just kind of
forced it into the
pushed it into the trap shut the lid and
done deal
but that i mean you don't know if it's
right it's
it's showing signs of either being
distemper
or rabbit now a rabbit animal has to be
euthanized or taken yes sir taking
control like they're ha there's you
can't
there's no cure for rabies i use i have
to
in my part of the state i have to
euthanize the skunks because
there's so many of them have been found
with rabies that if i capture one you
know one in the wild
is one thing but if i once i capture one
we have it
they want me to euthanize it right
because then it could really affect a
person at that point yeah i mean
it's it's not afraid of people it's
coming around your house
you don't want to let that one go so you
don't want to relocate it because
it could have rabies it could have
another disease and then you would
transmit that to the rest of the
population
in that area yeah so i mean it's oh yeah
if it's out there stomping his feet in a
parking lot at noon i mean it'll be
washing your damn windows at [ __ ] 4
p.m
main street nocturnal animal a raccoon
you see a raccoon out in the
daytime something's wrong that's a big
sign now
so once you get that animal now to
euthanize you guys have you take it to a
certain place is it like kind of like a
bag and gas
kind of vibe or is it i mean we have the
state lets us do different
types of euthanasia gas chambers and
most popular
which is the co and you know
it just pain you know puts them to sleep
oh yeah we used to have a carbon
monoxide leak over at my buddy
jeff's house dude and so his nobody knew
right this is in 94 or 5 baby you know
and uh and we just started smoking we
we didn't even know about doing huffing
gas you know and next thing you know man
we go over there we fall asleep on
friday wake up on sunday baby
boy you know what i'm saying i mean dude
i woke up i felt damn nine months
old dude i felt so good man because he
had a gas leak in there you know so
every now and then a little bit isn't
it's not horrible but it's uh a lot of
failure
yeah a lot will kill you now if you have
so that's so that's a raccoon being
rabbit
well how do you know some of these other
animals are rabbits well i mean a
raccoon will act the same way
uh what what they'll like bill oh you
said it right we already said raccoon
what
are you talking about skunk oh that was
a skunk yeah the skunks are what i
captured the parking lot oh
that was that that uh that it's showing
signs of being sick either this temper
or rabies you know you i treat i kind of
treat them all
like they got something just like in
in the fire in my em fire department
setting like on a wreck i
treat you treat everybody like they got
something that way you're always covered
you always wear ppe you always wear your
gloves you don't say well he don't have
it don't need him you
treat everything like it's got it so
whenever i handle the animals i always
got my gloves on
you treat all of them like they would
have rabies just you don't so you don't
take the chance
um now
when you uh when you're going on these
house calls and stuff well
how about this what's the uh love life
like is it hard to meet a woman when
you're in the animal world do you ever
meet a woman on a call that you
ended up taking on a date sometimes i
couldn't imagine so i can't take too
many on dates oh you're married now huh
oh yeah i've been married for 23 years
did you meet your wife through animals
no
no no no i met i met her
oddly enough cruising the parking lot
back in the good old days back in the
90s
oh yeah we all used to cruise we got
crew sonic what they have
kmart oh damn really march yeah dude we
used to meet up at a michael they had
like michael's craft store
and we'd always meet up over by
michael's out in front of michael's on
like a
friday or saturday she don't like
telling it so i mean we met
cruz in a parking lot and it went from
told her i told her that night i was
going to marry her
and she just laughed at me and here we
are been married 23 years and we were
together for about two years before that
so
and she she likes it she's not some of
my animals aren't her favorite
she doesn't like go on call she'll go
maybe with me to check a
trap she won't get out of the truck um
she
i'll tell you a quick little story she i
had a bunch of when we were allowed to
relocate still i relo we got a 500 acre
farm
okay and i would let now when you say
you're allowed to relocate just clarify
so i know what we're saying
does that mean you're allowed to take
animals yeah like if i had some raccoons
i could relocate them on an approved
area they had to be
100 plus acres and had to be landowners
permission and i could
release them and so that was something
that was allowed by the state by
my area for your job in your area it's
no longer allowed no now i don't know
certain animals or rabies vector animals
okay so i mean if i catch a groundhog i
can release it right i get your squirrel
i can release it but some animals you
cannot raccoons
i can't release them not anymore so
anyway so i had about six or seven
raccoons and i was letting
i had my wife with me i said will you
video this and make a good video so i
said you video it and i'm gonna let him
go
and so she's oh here he is setting this
and i get the trap out and i set it down
and it
runs off and she's videoing oh it runs
off in the woods and i do two or three
like that
and then i get one up and i said this
one's for you baby i turn around let it
go
and it went right after went right next
to her feet scared her her death
screamed
that was the last time she went with me
when we let animals go
she was a little bit upset over that she
just scared now my daughter be right
there i'll bring in kit raccoons and my
daughter you know
she'll play with them and hold them and
she's all into animals
but it's i liked letting them go
i mean that was the better alternative
yeah i had to do what they i had to do
what my
state requires me to do right so some of
it's not always good but
what's an animal in look you can also
you don't have to have you ever seen
somebody had an animal they're not
supposed to have
and you let it slide that's their
business that's their deal yeah i ca i
don't enforce
i don't care what i mean i've been to
people's houses and
they've had pet deer and pet raccoons i
mean it's about something bigger than
that
i mean something bigger than that i'm
talking about have you ever seen
anything somebody got a damn
and you could just blink at me if you
have i mean
animals or other stuff animals or other
stuff well i've seen a lot of other
stuff oh yeah i have too many i've seen
full-fledged meth labs and oh hell yeah
you know i've
i mean i go into have you ever rescued a
rat or something out of the attic of a
meth lab
actually i did um in a in a town named
the town
um i was doing a bat inspection on a
apartment complex it was uh low-income
housing department you're just a
government run look if i'm on math dude
i promise you
i definitely think there's bats around
baby let's go so
i go into this place and i'm looking um
he says well we got
they had a back call and so i'm certain
they had like 18 buildings two story
bins so i'm cert i'm going through the
attics of all it took all day long
to inspect all the attic so i go this
one house and i said like nobody's here
in his apartment he said oh yeah we
hadn't got this cleared
to rent back out yet and i was like okay
and the
the guy the maintenance guy's downstairs
now i'm walking through the structure
and i get up to the attic and i get my
ladder open the door up i said
well what's up all the what's with the
white paint and all these little cards
hanging he said oh that's where they we
had a meth lab up here and they came in
decontaminated it
and they spray i don't i really don't
know it they paint they seal everything
up with type of paint
that if something's in the wood from
that meth lab it seals it up to where
it can't harm anybody oh i see what
you're saying and so i go up and do this
adding it's all
like this just bright white in here and
he's got all these little
these little cards hanging is supposed
to detect any type of chemicals if
something's still lingering
interesting so and i was like okay it's
like a little paper almost of sorts yeah
it's just like a
it had just an indicator if it something
detected something it changed colors or
had a little gate meter on it
so that was a meth lab had been cleaned
up and that was a different one but i've
found full-fledged ones
before i mean i go into million-dollar
homes and i go into places that ought to
be burnt to the ground
but i mean ever it's everybody's house
and if people's doing meth that's their
business
i'm not i'm there for them you know
people oh i'm sorry man out here let me
i'm like no i don't i mean i've seen you
name it i've seen it really
and i just you know you know when i go
into the house and i'm looking
for a bat yeah you know i'm not on in
your kitchen i'm going
underneath your bed right i'm going in
your closets i'm looking into places
that
usually people don't look in your house
so you probably see some water
a lot of stuff yeah a lot of drug
paraphernalia a little bit of everything
yeah
let me use it you you see everything
some stuff you know they're like oh
they'll get
they'll be like oh my god here i'm sorry
i didn't know he's gonna look here and
i'm like dude i don't know i don't care
don't you ever see anybody hiding in
that person's house or something like
that no but i see where they've hid
stuff
you know stuff they don't want people to
know i go up in the attics and i find
you know you'll find stock's old nudie
books up and down years ago
old beer cans um uh
sex toys oh yeah she knows hidden up in
that i mean everything over i mean
you do it long enough you find every i
mean i'm underneath the houses
i'm in the attics i'm crawling through
the closets looking for stuff
you're going to run into stuff you're in
the nooks and crannies baby and some of
it's kind of nasty
you know when you're in there i mean
do if i'm at a place doing a rat job
you know clean good houses and clean
places can get rats i mean they're there
for the food source but if you have a
dirtier environment it's going to
attract
more bugs rats mice
and it just gets nastier have you been
in some places
that it gets pretty bad take you know
take me on a take me on a tail
oh i did a single wide trailer
several years ago way out in the country
rural setting
and the complaint was rats i said okay
and i
got my stuff so i'll come out do an
inspection and so i come out
and they got chickens chicken coop right
in the backyard chickens running around
right next to the trailer
piles of crack corn feeding their
chickens
they got multiple dogs outside great big
bowls full of dog food
this could be my sister honestly so i
know where the rats are going to be
there oh you know already where they
going to be i know they're there because
of food source
okay right so all that crack corn dog
food crack they got to have a food
source got it
and so i go inside and as soon as i open
the door up i
seen a rat run through damn and so
here's this
man and woman in the house and had two
children
an older child and a younger child and
it wasn't the cleanest of conditions but
i mean i can't judge
right i'm not there to judge how anybody
is you know
and i'm just there to do my job so i
talked to her and started investigating
it was so bad in one room
that i went in the room and there was a
um
the my generation know you may when you
used to take top off a soup lid
so you take the ca now they're just
peeling up you pull the paint just top
off yeah you had to cut the top off
when i said why are there soup lids
nailed all around the walls on the base
at the baseboard oh that's where the
rats chew through and each time they
chew a new hole
we nail a soup can lid over top that
so i knew that's gonna be a bad job i
mean it was
such a bad infestation that i'd catch a
rat
and it would get eaten before i got
there
like it she get up in the morning and
check all the traps and say okay we got
some rats
and so i'd schedule it to come over
there when i would get there i found
just like the back legs
left bones the rats are they'll
cannibalize each other
now will they only cannibalize each
other once they've been caught so they
don't like give any information well the
other one's not gonna sit still long
enough
unless it dies but what i'm saying is
like um
do the rats realize okay you know henry
or whatever
got caught we gotta kill him so he
doesn't tell anybody else wait so
of course he's already dead or here here
henry he's food we're gonna eat him now
so i don't know they i mean it like i
said mother nature's cruel
once again you know it's cannibalize
each other the rats but i mean it's
and they're there for the food source
and left uncontrolled they'll get in
your walls and ceilings and
you know i think we end up catching 30
40 rats out of there and got rid of all
of them
now have you ever had anybody i'll tell
you this i was at this is in new york
city i'm in new york city
and i met a man from iowa who used to
his friend sold the penis
he sold raccoon penis
necklaces this is what the man told me
right in the street
and i thought that first man was crazy
and then i got his phone number you know
because it sounded interesting and i
haven't looked at my phone in years but
i bet it's in there and
is that a dude have you ever had anybody
call you and say hey you know
uh mr voyage will you help me collect
some of that you know i'm trying to do
something or i'm going into a business
you know rabbits feed or something when
you help me collect
an item along the way i could have
brought something for you i got a whole
box of
[ __ ] penises yeah i save them every time
when
i don't the the fur value so bad now the
markets just
kneel and how much fur is on the raccoon
penis well i mean for the diamond
the animal the like for the like in the
winter time like if i kept for fur
trapping i catch a raccoon
and i'll ski i'll skin it out and keep
the fur
and sell it in an auction fur auction oh
okay this is this getting outside
the wildlife bit this is a trap back to
the just trapping part
and you would you scan it out dried out
and sell it at auction where they used
to back in the 70s you might have got 30
for a a raccoon belt now you this the
pelt
yeah just the pelt now you might the
last year's auction i went to
they were 50 cents up to five dollars
damn yeah so that's
that's not worth my i won't i don't
spend the time to do it right i don't i
don't go out
and specifically trap for them but when
i
do it and when i do if i catch one i'll
take it back skin it out
and if it's a boar i'll keep i'll keep
the pecker i mean they're
they're worried i mean you can there's
guys that buy them they make toothpicks
out of them
really yep they have to make toothpicks
out of them can you pull up a picture of
that sean
raccoon penis toothpick and so is it how
much bone is on that penis brother
be honest i like a pencil i mean you'll
wow name so it's
it's i could have brought what you
should have i wish we talked about that
i brought you one
so that's raccoon penis right there damn
it's hardy yep
[ __ ] dick toothpick damn that baculum
brother
that's i mean they're about you can sell
about every part of the animal and the
skulls were
you know in that the guys that do it the
skulls were something
the glands are worth something that you
know
actually some places i thought i think
louisiana thought they sell raccoon meat
a lot of people eat raccoons i mean i
haven't had it i've never tried i've
eaten groundhog i've eaten
uh bobcat bike straps but i've never
tried a raccoon
how's bobcat i've had pelican and i've
had dove
well they're i mean the buy it just
tastes like meat i mean you could
i mean i know guys in trapping groups
i'm on facebook they've tried a
coyote backstrap wow but i mean a bike
strap's a box i mean it's all meat once
you get the hide off of it
but to each their own we tried bobcat
just for the hay we tried it
but that was something i wouldn't eat we
eat every day
uh my grandparents i used to hear my
grandparents talk about eating
groundhogs all the time oh get that
young groundhog oh eat that now i've
actually had groundhog years ago
it's all right but i know i've eaten um
beaver
but the the animal
i got you yeah before we go anywhere no
i feel yeah
and it's a good dark red meat it's it's
really good you make beaver stew
yeah it's a really good meat out of
anything it that you would trap
outside i mean we do nuisance trapping
for beavers too okay but in the win
you know in uh fur trapping well no i
like beaver trapping
it's a good meat it's a dark it's a good
red meat it's a really good meat
i haven't had that i'm sure and i'm sure
i could probably get into it in this
area
you know uh because i spent about half
the year out here now it looks like
i'm sure i'll be able to get into you
know just more option for that meat
you know the further west you get they
they don't want you having any meat
i mean you can't go to the grocery store
and buy but you can buy it out at you
know
i'm sure select places or track no it's
i mean it's not usda inspected stuff
no dude i don't want it to be you know i
mean it's good yeah
i want that bootleg stuff i want the guy
who's got a cooler on this on his
on his passenger seat lake bieber
there you go i've had some brother
that's for sure um
so tell me about this though when you
get uh the
the bone of the raccoon the penis
do they um have anybody ever made like a
thing of necklaces or
i'm sure they have okay i mean i haven't
i mean but
i'm sure i'm sure there are people out
there have
it's amazing they have that much penis
on them they make a lot of teeth like
coyote teeth they'll make necklaces out
of them
bare teeth yeah i mean there's there's a
necklace out of one
yeah it's beautiful god it's beautiful
and once you polish it and clean it up
it's just
bone yeah just knowing where it come
from or what it is
i mean if i laid that out there you
would never know what it was i mean
unless you've studied that or looked at
it you'd never know what that was
oh hell not a stir dude i don't get on
ebay and buy them
oh i'd stir preserves with that thing
bro that wouldn't yeah you can get right
in there you can buy
i mean you can look on ebay and buy [ __ ]
packers
what's the largest uh
what is the largest uh animal penis
you've seen that's out there
and i won't tell anybody okay
i mean probably a coyote wow we don't
skin them i mean i don't
take those out but when you skin them
you got a skin around it
i mean it's it's bigger than the raccoon
the bone part is bigger than the raccoon
so some animals have bone in their penis
huh but we don't have it
i mean it's the animals the i don't know
what all animals i'm not that
and here you go right here now let's
zoom in on that brother yeah there's the
coyote let's go down this penis bone
chart and just let's get a look at it
here
let me see what we got here damn now
otter's got that heater on him huh
otter's got that dang rudder yeah
wow badger got that interesting piece on
him
that red fox don't have much on him dude
r.i.p or the weasel
yeah that weasel ain't got nothing boy
i'll tell you look i'll be real honest
about where i am on this chart i'm
probably about a badger
i'm i'm in between badger and otter
i'm not gonna say don't comment okay
okay no worries man no worries
i'm just trying to be you know uh you
know oh maybe i'm a little more badger
okay i'll be honest with you bro
i'm a little more bad um we got another
question that came in from one of our
listeners man we had so many questions
that came in for you um
we won't get to all of them but some of
them we we do have here
yo tvw hi how's everyone doing
my name is pk originally from east
africa i've got two questions
for the world life control fella
um the first one is have you been on a
call where
somebody decided to keep
a wild animal as a pet and then change
their mind
something like a monkey or maybe
something crazier
uh and if so what what was that
experience like
my second question is um what are your
thoughts on
people keeping um birds as
as pets you know things like pirates um
yeah what do you think about that my
stepdad his first wife she was really
uh i don't know what was wrong with her
but she had countless birds and then he
left her
but um what do you see a lot of that who
has
birds who has birds that's a good
question who has birds
i have five birds okay my daughter we
all have them we're family
how big are these and how loud are they
they can we have
two parrots they're she'll kill me if i
say this wrong indian
ring necks okay parrots we have we have
two of those
and one of one of them's talking the
other one's young they hadn't talking it
uh echo he he's quite talkative we on
discuss
brenton talked about bringing a pet
bringing something with me and it said
the hotel probably wouldn't like that
and i
asked my daughter she said only if i can
come
she wouldn't sit in the bird well maybe
next time we'll have her come too man
oh that's a beautiful bird yeah there we
have a blue and a green one
yeah oh they're beautiful and so now do
you rescue these out of people's homes
no
the these were these weren't rescues
okay now we
she does have a oh it's got a couple
parakeets
different types of parakeets and we have
a love bird which came from an animal
rescue it came from a uh
on as a bird rescue and it had been
i think it'd been abused it was
mishandled it wasn't handled properly
and it's like seven years old and love
is a battlefield brother and then she
got
she got it um i mean there's all there's
animal rescues where parrots weren't
taken care of
no big mccall no just animals arctic
just like dogs and cats can get abused
where animals aren't taken care of
mistreated and they
they're giving up now now what about
show animals anybody you know sometimes
you see like i know they had a cat show
for a while out there near
uh fresno they got busted and they shut
down and had a disband and get rid of a
lot of the cats and a lot of the
you know there's people you see i know
you mentioned earlier they got squirrels
i remember about it
um i don't know if it was dollywood or
someplace in arkansas they used to have
that little
you know the squirrel on the water skis
a little deal they put out there at
recess or whatever lunch you know
and you could throw a little barbecue
chips at them or whatever but have you
had any uh
animals that have have you had any shows
that have shut down in your area and he
met magicians and you had to go rescue
the dove or anything like that or reach
into a hat
you know like anything you've had to do
like where the the performance animals
well i i did get a call about white rats
and they were obviously domesticated
rats and somebody let go
and there's quite a few of them in this
kind of neighborhood but they were
coming to one house
okay and i mean i called caught all them
just like i do
any other rats but they were all white
so what did that mean
that somebody couldn't care for and they
just released it
okay but you don't know if they were in
shows or anything oh no no they wouldn't
in a show no
i don't not not where they were at they
weren't in the show i've never
i've never had to get anything that
somebody had in a show that were
something that was released now we i
think in ohio a couple years ago a guy
let
you know something don't know what he
was unhappy about but he had a lot of
exotic cats and he let them all
everything go and i think they ended up
having to euthanize most of them
they were just you know you let a cougar
go
you got you know the lion you can't you
know they're going to get somebody then
i think they euthanized most of but that
was somebody that
just let pets go that they shouldn't
have had to start with okay
so what tell me take me into the big cat
game what's that like when you get some
of these big cat calls and
uh what kind of cats do you deal with i
mean the only cats i deal with are
bobcats
now are they violent oh they're out of
all the
and back goes into the trapping part of
it the
the uh i catch a coyote they try to get
away from me i mean they're
if they're caught they're going to be as
far if there's a if it's a
if they have three foot of chain or
cable attached to that trap or a snare
they're going to be as far away as they
can get from you coward away from you
bobcat comes after you the bobcat
they'll flat come after you here's a
question right here that came in about
one video
oh there's a video you right here
dealing with one okay
wow
and is it chained down to the ground
right now it's caught in a foot trap
okay
and i like the red fox i don't like the
so this is a red fox this isn't a bobcat
yeah that's that's a red fox i like the
red fox they
they are on the euthanasia list in the
nuisance part
now this is this is fur trapping just
regular i'm trapping under my
trapper's license and i'll release all
them when possible because they just
don't see as many of them
and i just use a choke pole and so i let
him loose and he'll
bam he's he's all off to live the other
day
there was a girl i ran into a girl a
couple of months ago in los angeles and
she had a fox fur coat
and she was kind of wearing it laid out
she didn't want to tell everybody she
told everybody it was fake but then i i
felt like it wasn't fake you know i
touched it and i felt like
i said i don't know i felt some fake
stuff before and it feel like real stuff
oh they're very nice so she admitted to
me secretly she'd been doing drugs but
she told me secretly that it was
real so there's i mean there's a lot of
the fur industry is really gone
you'll see more actors actors um singers
sporting fur sporting bobcat that's the
biggest thing i i have several bobcats
that i've been that i've held on to
that i want to have made into a vest or
a coat and i have some
black or black coyotes that i've helped
that i've trapped over the years
wow and i want to have a kind of like a
black
coyote backing and bobcat front i'd buy
something like that from you
i mean it's i mean there you can i mean
the fur coat the
like the bobcats i sell that all the fur
goes to for the fur industry most of it
ships to like china and russia for no
liners for fur coats or jackets but like
the
bobcats there's a guy that would used to
buy mine into lexington kentucky
that makes custom furs coats and stuff
and he buys the bobcats for that
yes i i don't know if it's secretly
still a pretty big business or not
you know i mean it's i mean a lot of
people are down on it
i mean but a lot of people like it too
and a lot of people are down on what we
do
you know people don't like the trapping
yeah i mean it it
injures him sometime you know it it
catches him by the foot you know
it does hurt you know um it does do more
in
the more they fight the more they might
hurt themselves but
i've actually got in places to trap
before farms a trap in the winter
by taking a trap and sticking my hand in
it and just
usually like a number two one's not real
hard powerful it don't
break the bones break it don't feel good
but that lets somebody know okay well if
a dog does get caught in it's not gonna
break its foot off right
and if i'm willing to stick my hand in
it they're willing to let me track
because they don't fear what the cat
gets it is not going to kill the cat
right it just won't like it very well
but it'll be able to be released
unharmed i mean it's
kind of strange you know i do that but
some people do that you do
trappings getting harder and harder to
find places to trap
well it's weird that we're part of
nature but we
sometimes act like we're this
but we're this more conscious part of
nature i guess because it's not like you
probably have
some raccoons that won't come in and
kill the babies to get the mother to go
back and you know i'm saying it's not
like you don't have these other dirty
parts of nature that run its course
um you know i have a friend who does
some big game hunting
and he talks about how a lot of times
the the conservation the place you go to
hunt whatever it is
you have to pay like half a million
dollars to do it
and the money you pay it's usually a
sick animal that you're
killing or an old animal that's not
procreating
one out of the group yes and so the
money you're gonna pay
is gonna take care of 500 other animals
you know like um it's just interesting
sometimes like
uh how one news article
you know sometimes just won't give you
all the facts so at least you can make
um have a little bit more information a
lot they'll feed like they'll take that
animal too and they'll feed the whole
village
right oh totally yeah yeah they won't
even they might take a you they might
get some part of the animal taxidermied
or get a photo or something like that
uh for their relic but they're gonna
yeah but that
that the food from that could feed the
entire village and also but the money
for the conservation group
is going to it's going to bring it's
going to help so many more animals
live it's almost unbelievable you know i
mean the hunters have been
that money goes for the preservation the
to keep the poachers away
totally no the fancy or whatever and you
need it look i'll tell you this i was in
south africa this is probably
maybe eight years ago seven years ago
doing comedy shows over there
and we met a man one day and he was rich
this man was rich man he
and his wife had run a diamond mind
or mine and they
or hell who maybe was a damn diamond
mind maybe it was damn indiana jones
but they had run something where they
had made a ton of money but they owned a
nature preserve their own
i mean and this dude took us in the
helicopter and i actually ended up
hooking up with his girlfriend one time
i still feel pretty bad about that
but uh but anyway this man took us over
to their nature preserve and
and he took us around some of the
biggest animals that he might have had
damn dinosaurs i don't remember what he
had
but i mean he had trice uh rhinoceros
everything you know jeremy just we
pulled right up next to him they were
his
in his damn yard i mean his yard i'll
admit was probably 50
000 acres or something but it was a yard
fast forward two weeks
he sends me a picture the two rhinoceros
we'd seen
somebody broken in and saw their horns
off with a uh
chainsaw and just left the bodies right
there to rot yeah
and he said poachers have gotten in and
gotten them and it was they're trying to
protect them and
get the people there poaching just to
sell that little bit of ivory
off of them right so it's just
interesting it's like one thing's gonna
happen
it's just nature it's like this part of
nature is gonna happen
sometimes you have to do another part of
you have to
just it's about managing nature yeah see
that's what my
i mean it's got to get in the away from
the noose the wildlife part it
like by trapping my daughter doesn't she
doesn't like me getting all the animals
that
no but she she loves animals right but
i we keep him in check you know this
year
um i trapped 66 coyotes wow and over the
course of the four-month trapping season
you know think how many coyotes i took
out of the population
all those females which over half of
them were females
they're going to have all those young
you know all the baby deer that i saved
all the young turkeys that i saved all
the i do a lot of work for uh
sheep farms and all the baby sheep oh
sheep will get attacked and sheep is
just a damn [ __ ] throw pillow full of
dinner dog
they'll get them [ __ ] immediately so
i just immediately we got to keep it in
check
you know everything's got to be kept in
check or if not it'll
um like the deer i mean that's why they
have deer seasons
and they keep upping the quota if they
didn't have a deers if you weren't
allowed to kill a deer
i mean your insurance that's what makes
your insurance cost so much now is all
the wrecks
right i mean where i live that deer deer
collisions are horrible
i mean i've got friends have hit 10
different deer in their life total cars
i mean it's
they're there and if we didn't have
these seasons to keep them in check
there'd be just that much more of them
on the road crossing the roads
just like all the other animals if there
wasn't but it's all in a
balance like the groundhogs are starting
to come make a comeback
and why are they doing it what's going
on their main predator was the coyote
oh so i'm killing them so if you take
too many it messes up the cycle
you take too many coyotes out and then
the
groundhogs are going to get
overpopulated damn so i mean
everything's got a
spot everything's got a little spot in
that food chain
but i mean they have to be kept in check
i mean people you know it's it's part of
it mother nature does it herself with
disease and stuff you know
we're just giving her a little helping
hand no look i think it makes perfect
sense like you're saying if you don't
take those coyotes out
then how many more turkeys do they get
into how many more baby deer do they
kill
how many more uh chicken houses
just different things how many more
different circles will they mess up i
mean
bobcats they'll a bobcat take down a
full-grown deer damn
i mean they a bobcat goes for the neck
well
attack no a cat goes for the neck canine
usually go for the rear they bite no
they
they type from the rear but you know a
bobcat they'll take down
and pets both of them will take down
coyotes or big pet killers
because cats if you we got cats that are
around dogs
i have a little healer the cat's not
scared of the dog so a coyote could walk
right up to a cat
and just just take it with it because
the cat got scared of it
oh cause they're the same species well i
mean where they're they're used to
my cats used to doc no most cats are
used to cats that are outside are used
to i'm not talking about bobcats now i'm
like a domesticated house cat
okay or used to dogs and so if a coyote
walks through your yard and the cat's
there the cat's like hey what's up oh
you see it's a dog
yeah and it thinks it's just a dog and
bam you know coyotes are starting to
come into our neighborhoods and eating
the pets because they're easy meals wow
and they'll eat they'll eat small dogs
they'll eat that bobcats
don't know if they're real they'll eat
another cat if it's out and we
know if they can get to it they're
they'll eat they're a hunter they'll eat
whatever
they can come across my god
but they they killed i mean i've seen
videos
on cameras where coyotes were attacking
deer bobcats were attacking deer
do you feel sometimes like we're kind of
ruining the world and that we it's like
kind of a bummer that we're in it not in
a bad way like
but just do you ever like have that
moment where you're like man nature
would be so much worse
we're asking them to live in their
area that's your journey after no that
you look i think you have a good
you got a unique position because you're
that you know you're kind of that middle
man
you're that middle man where it's like
hey man whenever you know somebody
starts
you know stepping on when it's you know
red rover red rover a coyote came over
you know i'm saying you're the guy they
call
yeah you know like you're that freaking
you're the you're the referee kinda
yeah so i think getting your perception
is interesting that
yeah we're kind of if you so you would
say it feels like we're
on their turf in the world yeah i mean
it's we're
uh bats will go into bats uh you know
they mainly they'll live in trees i mean
bats are everywhere
and they'll live in trees and the more
trees and structures that we remove to
build houses
and whatnot they're going to come live
in your house right once again
it's just a big tree to them here's a
question we got that came oh there's
some video right here you dealing with
one of them yeah
that's a photo yeah that's one i removed
from from a house
wow i mean they they have canines if you
you see their teeth i mean they have
canine just like a
it's like a dog and they got the big
canine teeth yeah i mean they
they can inflict a pretty good bite on
you so i mean don't air you see a bat
don't just call call the professionals
and let them
i've got i've got all protective gloves
you get bit by him and he flies off
dude you're getting rabies shots and you
don't have to go do that that's pretty
pretty nasty shots have you seen someone
die of rabies
no i haven't i know i know several
people personally have had rabies
i've done a couple jobs where the people
had such a bad bat problem
they've already had they've gotten bit
and already had to get rabies vaccinated
shot or rabies shots
and still haven't got rid of the bats
damn so just
some people just i don't know just don't
understand aren't educated or slow
learners or
if i got rabies shots i'd probably be
getting rid of bats if i had them that
bad
yeah i think but i mean they can bite
you if you have one in your living space
i mean they could bite you and you not
know it when you're asleep
enough to know just a little prick and
you not notice it and there you go
so do um have you had uh
anybody have you had any senior citizens
living with animals they didn't know
they were living with like any crazy
instances like that
um i had an elderly lady that
she kept hearing something and there was
possum in her house
it had come in through one of the vents
in the bedroom that she hadn't used for
a while pushed the vent up
and it was running around the house she
she actually thought it was a cat
and she just caught they always think
that glimpses of it but i mean other
you know people not i mean that was
actually living
in the house with her amen no no others
would be under the house
and and uh i mean rocco they'll i've had
a customer sent me a they said they sent
me a message
texting me said we got a raccoon problem
can you help and i said yeah and i said
well you know it's a raccoon and they
sent me a picture
the raccoon had come through the
ductwork into the ceiling
in the kitchen knocked the register out
and were when you screw all that
ductwork together you use these big
metal sheet metal screws and it got
itself wedged up in them screws
and was hanging there and just a bloody
mess blood where he'd been trying to get
out all over the ceiling dripped all
over the floor
and she sent me a picture said we're
pretty sure it's a raccoon
i mean picture of the damn thing still
alive bleeding all over the place so
i couldn't i had to i went over as quick
as i could and was able to put somebody
on the bottom and when it took the duct
work off and captured it and got it out
of there
unbelievable but they'll get in some
pretty predicaments bad spots
now what's animals you won't deal with
i'm guessing probably for surely you
know big
large aquatic i'm sure isn't your deal
and uh
what else you think isn't um under my
license we can't
bear shark we can't deal in kentucky we
can't deal with deer
turkey black bear elk we're not allowed
to unless
who's that the police you call one of
the fish and wildlife
unless they give us unless the
commissioner of fish and wildlife says
okay
we'll give you permission to take care
of this animal but normally
those are certain type animals that i
can't like somebody's got a black bear
i can't help you so you're that middle
man kind of and now what's something you
won't go down and handle either i mean
you're not handling pests really you're
not handling
you know roaches or even large roaches i
don't like but i'm scared of spiders
okay i'd rather go wrestle a bobcat
underneath the house then get a spider i
hate spiders
yeah i'm damn i hate spiders yeah okay
my wife thinks it's funny i mean i'll
han i'll grab a raccoon with my bare
hands and gloves
i won't get a spider i don't like
spiders wow each his own i don't
but you don't do pests so you don't do
so no i don't do incest no i'm not
licensed but i'm licensed wildlife i
don't do
i don't do the bug work i mean that's
that's more com
it's it's more licensing because you're
spraying a chemical inside the
house with people do you look down on
those people at all like it's kind of
easy
i get they give their i mean the bug
guys
they call me animal guys but they're i
mean i get we get a lot of work from the
pest control because they get they get
past call somebody gets a raccoon
they look up the phone book and they
call pest control exterminator
and so then that exterminator calls me
says hey marty we got
customers got raccoons take care of it
right or then i'll go to a house
and oh and i'll be doing a job while i
find termite damage
when i'm in uh crawl space or you know
something like that and hey
yeah i recommend this guy yeah and then
we help each other out now we pass it
back and forth
right and we just be in professional
courtesy and help each other
i scratch your badger you scratch mine
yeah there you go
and then some guys do both yeah a lot of
guys have their
pest control license and wildlife
license okay
but i just had the one but i mean the
bigger just bigger company and then
while or pest control is a big big
business yeah yeah it's a lot of
business yeah
it seems like it um would you get calls
every day
yeah i get i mean i'm not big you know
hundreds of calls a week but i get quite
you know it varies you get slow
i might get a bunch of calls and it
might not phone might not rain for a day
or two
but i've always got jobs going on so i'm
staying right because some of them take
a couple days a couple weeks well some
yeah some of them take a while bat jobs
i've got several bat jobs scheduled
already
for this spring you know i keep be i'd
like to be
i don't want to be big i've got one guy
i don't want to be busy or not
i want right i don't want to get i don't
want to grow
too big i mean it'd be good to grow but
then you have more people
you have more responsibilities more
responsibility more vehicles more
insurance more liability no it's a lot
yeah and then i won't
lay then i'll be home at laying awake
worrying about i got
jobs work for this guy and this guy can
make this payment
i i'm happy with what i'm doing me and
one guy
and that's keeping me happy tim you said
his name man yeah timmy cooper he's a
he's my farm hand he's my wildlife man
he's home right now putting an engine in
one of our race cars oh really
yeah he's getting we're getting ready
for race season so he's working on that
right now
okay so the summer time is rate like so
what kind of racing you guys do
uh compacts it's cavaliers honda's
i race a uh cavalier okay so you get out
there and ready and uh track
racing yeah so how often do you guys do
that yeah every weekend so this is a
dirt track right over here
oh there is yeah literally yeah there's
that was last year's car
hulk racing right there yeah hawk
wildlife control and that's your car
right there yep that's my car
and that's your company yeah that's my
company hock wildlife control yes sir
um and i'm the driver amen baby now i've
got another car this year
two of them this year and steve is going
to drive it
now who is timmy the guy that works for
he's going he's going to drive the
second car okay
and is he uh and so now let me see what
kind of cage zoom in on that please
what kind of cage you got you know what
that is
that is a i bought that car already
built that is a front of a shopping cart
look at that now look after i said that
and you look at that that's the front of
the shopping cart
it is upside down i love it now my new
car
that i like this one the new car that i
like you got pictures of it too and it's
got a custom built
roll cage i mean it's top-notch a good
friend of mine corey lewis from 1107
motor works
at home where i live at he built me a
custom yeah that car he built me
he built me a custom cage and now how
fast this thing goes
uh we'll go 70 mile an hour 60 seconds
so what are the rules in this
what is this what is this branch of
racing called again this is
compacts so hornets compacts four
cylinder class
it's a four cylinder motor so only a
four cylinder is front wheel drive
there's four cylinder rear wheel drives
and front wheel drives so these things
you can't even get them going that fast
anyway if you wanted to know you can
you can spin you can spend a lot of
money on them i don't
um i've got a i've spent i spent way too
much this year i mean you can go out and
spend
four or five thousand dollars if you
want on having the motor built wow
just a ecotec just wants to run around
they're in cavaliers or in
those h8 during a bunch of different
chevrolet engine but they're just it's a
cheaper class i mean you get the
cavalier it's affordable
yeah it's it's affordable class it's and
you go up late model or
modified or sport mod and you're getting
bigger motors
so what what cars so what gears and
types of cars can be in this class of
racing
the our track rules is for it's got to
be front wheel drive and four-cylinder
that's it
yeah anything else okay take me to a
race to that on youtube sean real quick
i just want to see something
we have a local dirt track right there
in my home in my home county wow there's
several around us and
how often will you guys race i mean we
could race i mean i ra we race every
saturday night
when the season starts and then they
have other tracks that race on friday
nights and some race on a sunday so we
could go all over
there we go wow so that's dirt track huh
it's fine
is it yeah is it pretty dangerous or not
really yeah it can i mean we wear
full fire suit helmet i mean it can i've
never got i mean i've never wrecked
other than hitting cars i've never had
to roll over or gone off
i went off the bank once last year but
they would drive right back on but
i've watched a lot of guys get hurt in
it you can get hurt in it how much does
it cost to be in it
what to to have the car or just a race
yeah just take me through the costs
i mean like i mean to race the 30
pit pass and i'm racing that night wow
just dirt just entrance fee
and usually we get like if we
if we run the feature you get a you get
a 20
start money you get 20 back out of that
if you win no
just to start just to be in the future
yeah everybody gets say there's 15
to feature you get that start money back
even though you don't win
and then i think our club what does
feature mean you get in the top 15. the
the big race you got hot laps you got
your hot laps and
then you go you gotta you hotline
qualify yeah you're qualified
and then you then go up to get your
feature lap then you're featured
sometimes you get depends on how many
cars you have you have one feature two
features
but our our particular truck i think
they're paying out this year 800 for
first
wow five per second that's a lot of
money for a little compact
yeah it is man and how uh how long is
the race
uh but ours is 15 laps wow
so what does that take maybe 12 12
minutes yeah
it takes i mean you're moving on versus
some tractor archer's a longer track and
some tracks are shorter
i mean it seems like it's forever when
you're out there and you have a lot of
cautions and you got sitting weight or
somebody wrecks and they got cleaned up
all the drag it off the track and you'll
be waiting i mean sometimes you might be
out there 20 minutes
but there's no pit stops or anything no
you can't in ours there's no pitting
there's no
if you go i've i've run races with flat
tires just kept on going yeah
they till they tell me stop they they'll
rip black flag me
ready you know get off the track then
i'm done
so anybody with a four-cylinder car
could go get a pit pass and get in that
race
yeah and as long as it's got a pro you
know roll cage approved and you've got
your safety gear
they'll get in and some of them inspect
them pretty close but
i mean you got to have a helmet you got
to have safety your your clothes fire
extinguisher
but i mean it's a fun dirt track has
been in my area for years and years
yeah they had bombers and stock you know
stock cars bombers and now we're getting
it's just an affordable class it's just
one that
my first car i paid 1200 for it ready to
race it borrowed a helmet and was racing
yeah and this year i built a new
bot a car bought an old car
motor blowed up and had it all fixed up
and repainted and
new body panels put on it and then
putting in a built-in
having the motor built put in it an
all-new cage built new racing seat
and it's it's just a fun way now you're
getting into it now yeah
i mean i'm advertising it's it's
business yeah it's
right off from my business i like it i
like it wife likes that it's a ride off
it's fun
it's fun honey i gotta go do some
advertising tonight yeah
there's quite a few wildlife guys
actually i know now you know it would be
cool man
and i'm just going to give you a free
idea here and this
is you put a cage in the back you throw
a couple animals in that [ __ ] while
you're
[Music]
they drunk frown on that well i don't
know would they
but you do you want to talk about
horsepower talk about raccoon power
there you go
put a bunch of mean pissed off right
yeah dude like damn it's got eight
raccoons
it's got it's got 280 horsepower it also
has eight raccoon power in it baby
it's not a bad idea really but they pay
for the car really
you guys like catching raccoons and
animals help pay for that car let them
enjoy it brother let them enjoy the ride
man some people do different things for
enter you know go out clubbing
now go we go racing well then the kids
will want to come by and see your car
before the race you know what i'm saying
there would be oh well they come down in
the pits and they look at the cars and
take pictures i love the kid
we do there's a thing they call running
the track in before the race where
where they're getting the track ready
and they go it gets a little bit too wet
where they water and we go run it in
just dry it out and we're we just we
just go slow we don't go real fast and
i'll take we'll take kids we can have
somebody go with us oh that's cool
you talking about making you know a
little 10 year old day him riding that
car
i bet oh man just they love it you know
get to ride in the race car i mean
we're not nascar but no but to them you
are yeah i mean it's
for where i'm at it's kind of like no
we're nascar or oh
race car to a 10 year old being on a
track made out of dirt which is one of
their favorite things
we have a he's i guess 11 now
last year he was racing um a compact
and he had a sport mod wow and he's 10
years old
and he i race against a lot of kids that
are 10
12 14 years old and here i'm 48 and i'm
racing against 10 year old
oh look man that's the world today man
it's you know we got to compete with the
young brother the competition bring it
and those are the ones that'll make it
bigger will make race car drivers
started out young yeah totally yeah yeah
maybe let's
maybe we can leave out if there's a
story that you want to tell us something
maybe some like a wild
experience that's happened over the
years um
another one out we were discussed
get a call from a i do a lot of a lot of
local work but sheriff's departments
police department
they'll give me calls they get a deer
stuck in the fence
or now will they sometimes call you when
they just don't want to deal with
something well they're just not their
field
no they get i'll get a call like we got
this raccoon and somebody's got a pet
raccoon
mm-hmm or they'll call me or um
police i this happens a lot um
old i don't have you know a wit a person
at home
residence and they hear something and
think somebody's breaking in
it's a raccoon and they're at it they
think it's a person up there of course
so then the cops are you know they'll be
like well we know marty let's
know here here's his number and they'll
call me and then i'll come out and try
to take care of it for him
but i get a call one night and it was
real it was i don't know
one or two o'clock in the morning i get
a call from a sheriff's department a
couple counties away
from their dispatch so we need your help
we get they're on a traffic stop and
they have an unusual occupant in the
vehicle
and i said well what and they said well
they said it might be a deer
i said okay so i grabbed a big dog dog
crate and
my daughter wanted to go she was still
up we were night owls
and so she goes with me and so i go we
travel there took about an hour to get
there and i get there and there's
all the cops are all on the side of the
road and they got the guy out there and
they're doing the
they're still doing a sobriety test on
him where he was drunk
and i get up to the car and there's baby
deer in the front seat
and what was he doing just sitting there
well the guy had to pet deer i mean the
guy's driving around drunk with that
deer in his car
oh hell yeah in the front seat and they
i think actually they tried i think they
got him for wanting endangerment maybe
with like a passenger for because
there's an occupant oh
but danger in that animal i guess that's
and uh it was tame
i mean it been bottle-fed and so my we
get the deer out put up my truck
now you got pictures he's got pictures
of that there they had it in my truck
bottle feeding it on the way home was it
in the front seat or back seat
that was in the front side of the car
hell yeah they're right in the front
seat i never had seat belt david
could have been a damn date dude
honestly well not a little young
but i mean he had like you talked about
the bling it had a big fancy collar on
it they hit a collar a little duck
pretty dog collar on it and it
look it's hard to meet somebody man in
some areas you know
no judgment it is but what it found out
the guy had
just like i talked to you before he
found it on
a band and said it was orphan wow picked
it up you know
and kept it because he didn't think
mommy's around but we kept it for a week
or so my daughter
she bottle-fed it and then we took it to
rehabber and they
about i didn't check by me they raised
they'll bottle feeding raisins and turn
them loose
take them out in the wild any wild
horses or anything ever been called or
anything
just anything like that any wild horses
no trying to think of any other animals
that really are
um it's nice to know where this middle
ground is
i get turtle calls i've done some you
know people just what are they up to
snapping turtles in their ponds
just don't want snapping turtles in the
pond you have to go can you get in there
i just oh i don't do turtleman i don't
go in and wrestle the turtles and who
does that
well the the turtleman guy i don't do
the oh you call a reptile guy
yeah he's uh he had a show on he's in
from kentucky
turtleman oh i never saw it yeah you
said tv show on
did he yeah he don't uh it's not on
anymore he would go into ponds and
actually grab him
um yeah there you go he is actually
a good friend of my good friend ronnie
vincent it helped me get started in the
wildlife business
and he actually is a turtle wrangler
that's what he was known for damn
he goes in there feels for him and grabs
them by the tail and pulls them out
i just use a jug and a hook and catch
them and
get rid of them for them but it's
interesting that the whole
field it seems like you know your
grandfather kind of got you into dealing
with animals and
it's just interesting that it like
in the same way that there's kind of the
food chain and mother nature that
the way that we learn things from each
other and a lot of it is by
another human showing us something you
know it's like
anybody could give you a book or send
you a link to a video but unless you
really have somebody kind of
showing you a lot of times it's really
how you get into things well it's that
like the trapping part to dying
thing yeah i've had um
a buddy he didn't know him at the time
several years ago he messages me
hey man i like i watch your i post all
my
catch pictures in the winter time on my
facebook page everybody wants to see my
all my everybody's fascinated with it
and loves to see all the pictures we'll
put a link to that what is it
it's just it's on my just on my facebook
page marty warriors
all right we'll put a link then i have
my business page
wildlife controls on facebook also
so he messaged me as one and said i'm
i'm i like your stuff can i get in
will you help me yeah and so for about
the next two years
he went and we became real good friends
we trapped i showed him he didn't
know a thing i mean his name was josh
brine maybe you'll get to see this
and we became good friends and i taught
him all about trap and
everything that i've learned over the
years and went out and trapped together
for a couple years and then he went on
his own now he traps
and hopefully he'll pa he's got two
daughters and hopefully maybe he'll pass
that down to one of them or get to pass
it on
i've helped several kid no he's not a
kid but i've helped several people like
that
pass that tradition off right which is a
dying tradition
is it yeah i mean you just don't see it
any i mean
who do you know it goes out and traps
coyotes in the winter it's just a dying
tradition nobody
i mean it's kind of a you know one year
my wife let me grow a beard
i mean i had a mountain man a pretty big
there you go big full
beard fun can't do it no more she won't
let me she won't nope
wow what happens she just don't like the
beards yeah oh i can have a beard if
it's neat and trimmed
yeah and she's going to kill me for you
i'm talking about her but i can if it's
all neat and trimmed i can have it but
rules is rules we need rules man we need
rules happy wife happy life there you go
that's what they say i believe that man
um now but tell me this so a trapper
what does a trapper do i just want to
finish that so i know exactly clearly
what a trapper is and what it does
mean trapper versus wildlife nuisance
wildlife
right so when you say like you go
trapping coyotes like what are you like
so when
when i'm trapping i'm fur trapping there
let me put it first
nuisance wildlife um getting rid of
animals that say i can't i don't keep
those first if i catch a raccoon it's
out of season
right i don't keep those animals right
and
fur trapping is in the winter months
from november to end of february
is fur bear season when i can go out and
trap you can go out trap
ground or go out trap coyotes raccoons
uh
fox beavers bobcats so it's just the
same as hunting season but it's first
yeah it's first it's fur bear season
first
season and you know it's a lot of young
kid you know a lot of people do it the
old timers and pass it on and just
people learning i mean there's a million
youtube
videos about it and i mean i'm still
learning stuff every day and i watch new
new techniques and new methods you know
it everybody's got their own
method on how they trap or baits they
use or
bait and lure business is a huge
business is it trapping oh yeah they're
i mean they all make the similar baits
but everybody's got their best bait and
what's that top bait you use a lure what
do you use chicken liver
oh no it's like on my predator trapping
uh one of my favorite lures is jeff
dunlop lures
and he's just a big hardcore trapper and
has developed his own lure baits and
lures
and now what kind of uh meat if you use
a a meat or something you use
well most lures are made with baits are
made with
like muskrat meat tainted muskrat meat
oh yeah
it's aged and got preserved or
beaver meat that's tainted a little bit
to give off that
to to give off the smell for the that
predator oh yeah
sort of like uh like bobcat you know
they
the muskrat meat base bait they like
that scrat
pardon they like that scrap meat yeah i
mean it's one of the things they eat
right you know i mean they're beavers
bobcats love
beavers so let me name something you
tell me what eats it all right
uh groundhog
coyote okay coyote
a car damn i mean that's their they
don't have a name
i mean mankind man's the coyotes
predator okay
so the food chain should have a damn
volvo in it huh yeah
i think that's kind of good man sean
what do you feel like any questions
today
i feel like we covered a lot of good
stuff man do you feel like you gave out
a lot of good information
i mean i had more i mean but we we kind
of got off on other
i didn't think about i didn't know we're
going to talk about predator fur trap
in the race but that's that's all good
you know that's all well it's all
interesting stuff you know some of that
is i i think
myself and even a lot of our listeners i
would love i think 180 i didn't know
that there was access
to be able to go race cars if i wanted
to like that
so you know to know that if i were to
put together
you know you said it's about a five five
thousand dollar automobile you have to
put well i mean it's
the you can go out say you i mean
we get them i get on my i'm always
looking for cavaliers that's what i race
if you get on facebook marketplace i'll
find a
cavalier 800. runs good boom
snatch that sucker up strip you know you
strip the whole interior out
throw your roll cage in it you know you
can use the stock tires or put racing
wheels and tires on it bead locks
you can zoop up the motor add some
modifications to it and you gotta take
all the glass
all the glass tail lights out of it bam
go racing slap yours
some guys just take a spray paint can
paint a number on them
some guys but i've got several sponsors
so i'm lucky to
me i don't have a lot but i got enough
to where i can get some grant
some real graphics done yeah but i mean
it's a
i mean anybody can get into i mean you
got a little bit of money go out get a
car i don't know
every track's different they all have
their rules but this is
country down home country dirt track
racing yeah and saturday night yeah i
mean
just about every weekend you're going to
see a good fight usually fights break
out
people one guy's pissed at the other guy
you hit me and you
did this and getting the fights i mean
it it's pretty it's fun you know it's
all for all there's babies running
around there
to people in wheelchairs yeah it's fun
for all it's a good
my daughter is going to go work with our
racetrack this year she's going to help
work the gate so
everybody get everybody in the family be
involved in it kind of so
i'll race she'll be helping with the
gate oh it's it's fun it's a good way to
blow off steam
yeah we don't i don't club and party do
all that scene so we go
saturday nights we go racetrack i love
that oh i love that man
no look man i think it's really
fascinating stuff
you know i appreciate you uh so much mr
voyage for joining us today and honored
to be here
yeah man it's really really cool and uh
and we'll put links to where people can
check you out or hire you and you're
mostly in the
in the kentucky area yeah i do in ohio
too okay across the river ohio river in
ohio
okay so yeah man if you guys want to
meet the magic man
somebody's got to work somebody's got to
work the middle ground of the animal
kingdom huh
and that's who he is the middle man
himself thank you so much mr voyage all
right thank you very much now i'm just
floating
on the breeze and i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground
[Music]
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
on my heart shine
that light on me
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
just
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
[Music]
built